nous avions rencontré rené gina au chc
le dépôt les mets légers en 2019
leur histoire d'amour avait débuté là et
ils vivaient ensemble depuis des années
dans la même chambre ont chacun leur lit
au ch et celle des deux personnes
atteintes de spina bifida qui partageait
le même appétit de vivre malgré la
maladie
rené avait demandé la main de gina en
il s'était marié à l'église et avait
ensuite célébrée dans leur ch et celle
des cantons handicaper lourdement
commissions communautaires
je pense que ça a aidé beaucoup début
avril
gina apprend qu'elle est atteinte de la
coved 19
moi j'assume coulant courage et en lui
disant j'ai noté forte toute ta vie tu
t'es battu puis tu vas voir tu vas
passer à travers leurs chevaux mais la
maladie progresse gina est transférée
sans mener à l'hôpital ascap le répète
tout ce que je vois mon départ j'ai pas
elmer aux soins intensifs 48 heures
après son admission
son conjoint rené est abasourdi par la
disparition de sa femme
surtout qu'il apprend qu'il est lui
aussi atteint de la coved 19 lui
refusait tout il refusait de manger
refuser ni souhaitent ses proches le
convaincre de se nourrir et d'accepter
les traitements il est transféré au chum
où il aurait refuser l'acharnement
thérapeutique
il est mort samedi une semaine après sa
femme gina on se pense qu'ils se
pensaient pas pas juger les autres qui
étaient qui était leur piège qui a levé
pas question pour la famille de blâmer
le réseau de la santé
même s'il aurait souhaité pouvoir être
auprès d'eux à leur départ dans vie
montmagny ont pas avoir peur
puis on ait le goût de se réfugier de se
réfugier avec la personne drones hermes
ou les personnes qu'on aime c'est pour
s'entraîner tout elle avait parle mais
avait personne pour y tenir la mine dans
le ch est celle d où ils vivent l
angoisse grandi auprès des autres
handicapés qui vivent là une vingtaine
d'autres résidents sont atteints et sont
rassemblées dans une section pour tenter
d'éviter la contagion
ici david gêne-t-il et radio canada
montréal